what's going on it's your girl brittany
elena and i am here because bleacher
report
and ritz crackers are highlighting team
managers of the ncaa
and celebrating that impact that
managers have on a sport
we all love let's see what they've got
[Music]
[Applause]
hello jason what's up
the reason why i'm here is because ritz
crackers is on a mission to make the
world a more welcoming place
but to do that okay i think it's
important to understand what it
is that the team managers do for their
respective teams
so what does a day in the life of a team
manager look like
it's hectic but we'll start off in the
morning
we'll go get tested once i'm at the gym
there's a ton of work to do whether it
is
clipping up the film from a previous
game scouting up an opponent for
a future game rebounding passing hitting
players with pads
uh then practice which we're doing
everything we're keeping stats we're
running the the clock and doing all that
taping the floor
wiping up sweat how was your adjustment
when joining the team
my adjustment was super smooth it was
the environment that was already
inside of that program helped me
get adjusted and learned on the fly
everyone that i've
came in contact here will be my family
for the rest of my life and i'll keep in
touch with so
that also makes you feel welcome because
it makes you feel better and makes you
put in a position
of hey i can do this just like anyone
else can and so
that really made everyone feel welcomed
and a part of the team
has it been harder to connect and work
with players because of probate
yeah totally um in the beginning of the
season everything was sort of
compact and do a tight schedule but as
far as relationships and experiences
definitely not it's still
all the same i think it's created more
of a community environment and a
brotherhood feeling than
uh before i'm honestly super impressed
you really do
so much and i know that the team is very
grateful and thankful to have you but
here's the thing i need proof okay i'm
sorry
like i need to see in action so they
have set up a few
challenges to set your team manager
skills okay
first you'll have 60 seconds to clean up
the court and make it as
game-ready as possible that means
re-rocking the basketballs
spot checking the floor filling up the
water cooler organizing the team chairs
you know what you got to do
after it will finish up by testing your
skills behind the arc with a good old
three-point
contest are you ready
let's see let's see on your mark get
set go
all right look at him go okay put some
chairs down i'm gonna take a snack
another one chair down and it's all in a
straight line oh my gosh
filling up the water jug
jason you are killing it one two
bow footwork last two
all right show me what you working with
let's go let's go
two for two three four
three okay got excited now
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right jason you prove me wrong
amazing work
you got skills on and off the court
after such a tough year for team
managers across college basketball on
behalf of bleacher report and the ritz
practice i just want to say
thank you we tremendously appreciate
all the hard work and heavy lifting that
you and
other volunteers and community members
like you do
to bring this game to life because it is
a lot so once again just grateful and
thankful for you